speaking of adorable Sheldon's BFF
Leonard was also super cute in his youth
at least from the looks of this picture
lonard hoffstad who's played by Johnny
glei was 27 years old when we first met
him in season 1 of The Big Bang Theory
in this image though he looks to be only
about a year old we can't get over how
happy he looks to be sitting on the
coffee table in his teeny tiny overalls
this future physicist was already
wearing his prescription glasses and
probably solving equations at daycare
okay maybe not that but we have a
feeling he knew what sound a sheep made
at the very least and probably way
earlier than the other kids while we
love imagining him hanging out with his
future pal Sheldon even back in their
baby days this isn't actually Canon
according to the series in the season 3
episode of The Big Bang Theory the
staircase implementation it said that
when Leonard first put in an application
to room with Sheldon that was the first
time the future friends ever actually
met